JOE TIMMONS: In
today's session, we're
going to learn how Cardinal
Health moved thousands of VMs
to GCP.
My name is Joe Timmons and
I'm with the Google Cloud
Professional Services
organization.
I will be joined today
by Issy Ben-Shaul Shaw
an engineer in the
Google engineering
and a co-founder of
Velostrata, as well as
Louis Verzi, the lead cloud
engineer from Cardinal Health.
From our agenda,
we're going to be
diving in first as a baseline
into the cloud migration
introduction and concepts.
Then, we're going to look
at Anthos Migrate, which
is a new announcement that was
announced earlier this week,
which is the next
iteration of Velostrata.
Then, we're going to look at
the Cardinal Health experience
and what they did to
migrate thousands of VMs
in a short amount of time,
and the lessons learned,
and what you guys can learn
from that in your organizations.
And, then, finally,
we're going to take
a look ahead at the roadmap
of our migration tooling.
So, before we dive
in, just a show
of hands, how many of
you in the audience
are getting ready to do a
large scale migration to GCP?
Wow, pretty good.
How about those of you that are
doing cloud to cloud migration,
as well as on prem in the cloud?
Awesome.
Well, the reason I
bring that up first
is, I've been in professional
services for hyperscale cloud
organizations now for
almost five years.
And the conversations that
I am having today compared
to what I was having
five years ago
are an order of magnitude
different from the perspective
of where public cloud
is as a priority for IT.
4 and 1/2 years ago,
the public cloud,
it was all about
experimentation,
getting your feet wet,
trying to understand how
to leverage public cloud.
Fast forward to today,
it's all about mission
critical workloads,
moving entire data
centers to the cloud, and
how we can do it quickly,
faster and efficiently.
And that's where
Velostrata comes into play.
I also want to take a
look, beyond my firsthand
observations, at this survey.
This is a recent survey
of IT cloud professionals.
And they were asked, what
are your top IT cloud
initiatives for 2019?
The first one, not
surprisingly, is the things
that I got into
the public cloud.
I want to optimize their cost
and save my organization money.
But the other two are very
relevant to today's session.
The second being, I want
to move more workloads.
Right?
And the third is, I want to
more quickly adopt containers.
Containers are the new VM.
And everybody is
aware of how exciting
they are and all of the benefits
that you get from running GKE.
But let's imagine
that, for a second,
you wanted to take your
first ever trip to Europe.
Would you just jump on
the airplane and go?
I don't think so.
You would do some research.
You would buy a travel guide.
Your cloud migration
journey is no different.
You want to learn
from professionals
who have been there, who have
done that, who have seen it.
And that's where Google
Cloud professional services,
and all of Google, is here to
help you with that journey.
Especially when you see a
metric like on this slide, where
94% of respondents
to this survey
said that they face
some sort of cost
overrun, or some sort
of timing challenge,
with their migration journey.
Some of the aspects that we like
to highlight when considering
your own migration journey
are like at the top
here, where it says scale.
So are you guys
going to approach it
from just a few VM's,
a few workloads,
or are you considering
an entire data
center moved to public cloud?
Multi source.
So where the
workloads coming from?
Are you looking at bare metal?
Are you looking at virtualized
in your data center?
Or are you looking
at other clouds,
potentially, that,
for whatever reason,
you want to move that to GCP.
The next attribute
you want to consider
is complexity of the workload.
So is it a multi-tier app?
Is it a monolith?
What is it that you're wanting
to move up into the cloud?
And how does that impact
your migration timelines
and expertise that
you need at the table
to do it successfully?
And then, finally, risk.
So, most people, when they
want to move VMs to the cloud,
they do it in waves.
So let's imagine on a Friday
night during a change window,
you wanted to move some
VMs, and one of them
doesn't move correctly
and gets hung up.
Do you have a mechanism
to roll that back and not
impact your application owners
and not impact your business?
Because you want to
do your migration,
but you also don't want to
do it in a disruptive manner.
And then the one
thing that's not
on this slide I
want to highlight
is, don't forget about the
people and process aspects
as well.
So involve your
application owners.
Make sure that the
first time they
hear about your VM migrations
is not an email the week before.
You want to involve them
early so that they understand
the value proposition,
why you're
doing it to make their
applications better,
their application
development processes better,
and their businesses more
reliable in performance.
You guys have probably seen
this slide a lot this week.
And this is our
methodology for migrations.
And the reason we use this
a lot is because it works.
We have driven improvement.
And this is from
being in the field
and learning and seeing
multiple organizations
approach public cloud.
And it's the best
way to approach it.
So if one of you called
me tomorrow and said,
Joe, I would love your
professional services team
to help us move out of our
data center next month,
I would start with
this exact methodology.
I would start with a discovery.
What do you have?
What are the workloads?
What do your
applications look like?
How interdependent are they
on the other applications?
Next, we would look at
your GCP foundations.
You have to build a really
solid foundation for the success
of your overall GCP initiative.
And, from experience,
I will tell you
that the primary
areas that you really
want to focus on
around foundations
are security and networking.
You have to get your
ingress, your egress,
figured out correctly.
And you obviously have to
include your security team
to make sure that
you adopt cloud
in a way that conforms with
your organization's security
controls.
So you've got your
applications figured out,
you've got your landing zone
and your foundation built,
now you need to start
migrating workloads.
And that's, really,
what today's session
is all about, the tools
that we have to offer
you to accelerate that.
And I'm going to hold that
thought to my next slide.
And then, finally, optimization.
So once you get the workloads
there into the public cloud,
what can you do to
make things better?
And this isn't always
just about the app.
Here at Google, we invented
sight reliability engineering.
So maybe you want to
take your operations team
and make them think more of in
cloud manner versus an on prem
manner.
Maybe you want to
reinvigorate your CI/CD,
or DevOps processes,
or even start
to refactor your applications
into microservices.
And, OK, let's double
click into migration.
So what are some of
the methods that you
can adopt when considering
how you're going to migrate?
So the two most
common that we see
are re-host re-platform,
where we see around 60 to 70%
of organizations
approaching it this way.
And this is traditional
lift and shift.
And this is typically
the chosen method
because it's all about speed.
It's all about, I want to
get my workloads to the cloud
as quickly as I can and
efficiently as I can.
And this is the sweet
spot of Velostrata
and why so many organizations
use it in their GCP migrations.
The second is all about
lift and modernize.
So earlier this week, we
introduced the next iteration
of Velostrata, Anthos Migrate.
And to talk more about that tech
and how Anthos Migrate works
I want to invite my
friend Issy to the stage.
Issy?
[AUDIENCE APPLAUDS]
ISSY BEN-SHAUL: OK.
Thank you.
Hello everyone.
Thanks for coming to
the session today.
Thanks, Joe.
So I will talk, in
my session, about how
Anthos Migrate actually performs
the migration and what it does.
And we'll leave enough
time for my partner, Lewis,
to talk about how they actually
use the system in order
to migrate thousands of VM's.
And we'll focus, here, on the--
Anthros Migrate, just
for terminology's sake,
is actually the broad name
for all replacing Velostrata.
I might be confusing myself
now when I'm talking.
I'm still used to Velostrata.
But Anthos Migrate refers
to both the ability
to move VM's in
a lift and shift,
as well as the new capability
that was introduced today,
which I will talk about
more towards the end
of the session in the road map.
So how does it actually work?
So, essentially, the way that
Anthros Migrate is deployed
is, you take, basically, a
virtual appliance that you
deploy on premises.
And from then on, there is
another set of appliances.
This is what you see
on the left hand side.
And on the right hand
side, we automatically
deployed, in a
scalable fashion, a set
of two or more
instances that basically
are termed cloud extension.
But they're actually
used as sort of a proxy
to the on prem environment.
And, essentially, what
we do is, once you set up
a VPN and a VPC that
is set up, you're
ready to go and
migrate to scale.
So as Joe said, there is
a discovery session that
needs to take place early on.
And, basically, it ends
up with identifying
a set of VM's of workloads
that need to migrate as a set
into the public cloud or GCP.
And this set of workloads can be
either identified interactively
through the vCenter
plugin that we provide,
or through what we
call a runbook, which
is a utility that does
it in a batch form,
or even through your
own orchestration
tool of your choice
could be unstable
or any other orchestration
tool that you
have that can be actually
using our APIs to orchestrate
the solution.
The bottom line, you
have a set of workloads
that you want to run,
and move, and scale.
So all you do is basically hit
what was called running cloud,
and when that happens,
essentially, all the VMs
are shut down
gracefully on-premises
using our on-premises
[INAUDIBLE] appliances.
And then they're actually
streamed consistently
into the public cloud.
And we do it in a way that in
a matter of 5 to 10 minutes,
those workloads are up
and running in the cloud.
Now how could that
be if they have
a lot of databases and stateful
data associated with that?
That's the question
that comes up.
So, in the native
implementation,
that would not work.
So what we do here
is, actually, we
implemented one
optimized transport layer
that works in the way that even
though the compute is running
in the cloud and the
storage is still remote,
the performance is not degraded.
We use things like
predictive prefetch
of workloads that need to come
a priori before the users are
using them, caching, of course,
deduplication, compression,
things that we've been
working on for many years
to actually optimize and reduce
the impact of the latency.
So the bottom line is we have--
A set of VMs are running,
boot up natively in the cloud
while the storage
is remote, and when
you access the
storage or the data,
you access through the caching--
The appliances are in
the cloud, and they
fetch the data optimally
from their remote storage.
So this basically
brings you a set of VM
that operate in the
cloud in minutes, right?
Downtime for the production
applications is minimal,
could be five 10
minutes, and they're
up and running, which is
very important for validation
and for downtime purposes.
It can be up and running.
Now, once this is happening
in the background,
we kick off a
background process that
actually starts to
migrate the call
data, the data that they're
just not being accessed
right now by the applications.
And it runs seamlessly
without disrupting
the operation of the overall
workload that are already
running.
Once that data completes
this migration,
we're ready to go to
the next stage, which
is the conversion into
completely the cloud storage.
But for everything,
take the cache out,
flushing it, and getting
out of the data path,
and then run natively.
It's interesting,
though, to know
that we have many
customers that are staying
in this stage for
a while, because
an interesting
capability you offer
is the ability to
actually write back
the data that is being generated
in the cloud back to on-prem.
Why do we do that?
Because we want to allow
customers to roll back
if they need it because,
for whatever reasons,
the workload didn't
work as expected.
The performance isolates.
Some misconfiguration,
accessing too much,
a component is
on-prem, and latency
is a problem, et cetera.
And we've run into that, but the
ability to roll back instantly
gives you the option
to move faster.
I know that some customers--
I think Cardinal as
well-- had like maybe
5% of the workloads rolled back,
fixed, and then rolled forward.
So it's a very
interesting capability.
However, when you're ready
to cut the cord, so to speak,
you can actually do the
detached convert to completely
native storage, and off you go.
So this of at a high level, the
way that the system operates.
And Louis will
talk more about how
this is being operationalized
into a whole process
in which you decide the
experience, et cetera.
I will let Louis
elaborate on that.
One thing that's really
interesting about this
solution-- and it's
important for you--
is that is it an
ageless solution.
So one thing we don't do,
we don't install agents
on the workloads, right?
It's all done sort
of under the covers
through the hypervisor
access to the storage.
And what that means,
you don't have
to worry about opening firewall
rules for those application
workloads, you don't have
to worry about compatibility
with the antivirus and
interference with workloads.
As you know, I'm
sure enterprise guys
know that, if you can
avoid agents, it's better.
It also makes the whole
cutover process much more easy
and seamless.
So that's the solution
in a nutshell.
So let's move forward.
One of the things
that we invested in
is making it really easy
for enterprise customers
to start off.
And for that, we
integrated it very nicely
with the VMware vSphere.
We have a vCenter plugin
that plugs right into that
and give you the
experience that you need.
If you are a VM
wire operator, you
don't have to know much
even about the cloud
in order to start
rolling those migrations.
You get monitoring, logging,
built extended here.
And everything is done
through the vCenter
console, both for operation as
well as for monitoring logging.
As I said, if you don't want
to do it, you don't have to.
And you can still run from a
web UI or from the runbook,
but that's a very convenient
option to start with.
We also have a very
interesting tool
we call rightsizing
recommendation.
What we found out is there
are a lot of customers that
are worried about cost, right?
If I move like-for-like, my VMs
or other provisioning on-prem--
Usually, because I don't have
to pay for that other provision.
I pay for the host.
When I moved to the
cloud, I'm going
to be penalized because I am
going to pay for the instance,
and I need to pay
for the peak capacity
in order to make sure that
performance is as needed.
That's a problem.
But really what happens is that
with the tool that we offer,
you can actually
inspect the actual use
of those VMs, what are the
CPU and RAM, usability,
and utility, and utilization.
And then, with that,
you can actually
come up with recommendations.
So you see here, we recommend
if your cost-optimized,
you can actually
cut the cost by 5x,
compared to what you would
have done if you just
moved like-for-like in terms
of the size of the instance.
So it's another
tool in our arsenal
to help you make the
migration more cost-effective,
which is something that your
customers always worry about.
Some additional features
are of interest.
One thing that we
really care about really
is make sure, again, that
the risk off the migration
is reduced.
So we came up with
this utility called
Tesla, which means you can
test before you migrate.
What does it mean?
I can actually take a snapshot
of your VMware environment
and use that consistent
snapshot as a way
to stream it to the cloud
and see if it works.
So you don't disrupt that
all the running applications.
All is read-only
copy of the data.
And you can write it
locally in the cloud,
and you'll see things
work as they should work.
If they don't, nothing happened.
You didn't disrupt
the application.
So that is a very
powerful tool that
is being used very
extensively by our customers.
We are also in
automation runbook.
I'll let probably Louis
talk more about it.
But it's basically a way
to do migration at scale.
As you'll see by Louis'
presentation, when you operate
it properly, you can get
between 50 and 100 VMs
that are actually migrating
at once, and typically,
within a week.
So it could be very effective
with high throughput.
We support things like site
level bandwidth throttling,
because sometimes customers
obviously want to--
They don't have necessary
access to the QoS,
and they need to
control that to secure.
And we have also provide
telemetry, very extensive set
of counters for both
monitoring and logging which
is, by the way, now integrated
into Google Stackdriver, which
gives you visibility on
performance, availability,
and so on.
In fact, this is
actually a snapshot
of our telemetry information.
And I wanted to go
and show you what
does it look like in
real-world scenario.
Taken from one of our
customers, assuming
they went by the methodology
that Joe referred to,
you do discovery,
planning, scheduling.
And in the end of
that period, you
come up with a set
of workloads that
need to migrate as a
whole, as a cluster.
Once you do that and
you're ready to kick off
the migration--
This is using Velostrata.
You can see that, within
literally two hours,
we have about close to 80
VMs up running and GCP.
This is typically
what we see now.
The green line is
the actual data
that comes from the background.
But it's important to
understand-- realize--
that, from the beginning,
those are operational.
They are running.
They are operational.
And then the data count may
be a day or two days later
until everything completes
the migration in which case
you can detach when
you're ready to move on.
But, if you do it in
a pipeline fashion,
you can get into a very, very
nice cadence of moving again.
80-100 machines within one week.
And this is how, for
instance, calling on--
Other customers are able
to move thousands of VMs
within a relatively short period
of time within less than a year
using this methodology.
So just to wrap up,
basically, if we
see what are the benefits of
using the Anthos-Migrate for VM
migration, it's following.
The fact that we
can stream workloads
means that you can get quick
validation and reduce downtime.
And within minutes,
you actually get
your systems operated involved.
By the way, this is web
vSphere, WebLogic, even SAP.
So all the complex multitude
workloads that are out there
are supported and validated
with a lot of customers
that have used it in the past.
So that's one benefit.
And then I mentioned it's
agent of solution, which
means that the overhead,
the labor, they
need to invest in order to
get that solution working.
It's dramatically lower.
It's much seamless.
It's very automated.
All the transition from
moving into on-prem,
into running in the cloud
is completely automated,
injecting drivers that know how
to work with the cloud storage,
connecting the networks,
reducing and removing
some agents, et cetera,
cleaning up the image.
All this is done automatically.
And that means that
by certain measures,
we compare to traditional
replication solutions
with agents.
It could be easily
five or two 10x less
overhead in terms of that.
I mentioned risk mitigation
critically important
for enterprise CIOs, they
need to make sure the uptime
of their applications.
And that's also very important.
The tools to test
before you migrate,
which means that you can test
everything before you actually
decide to move your production
workloads or roll back
if things don't go well
in a matter of minutes.
So this is also very important.
And last but not least,
the whole completion
of the migration is about 5 to
6x compared to other solutions
faster.
Once you start on a journey
of data center migration, you
on a boat, you're going
to get it over with as
soon as possible,
because maintaining
two infrastructures,
paying for both.
Dealing with synchronization
impacts is a real hassle.
You'll be asked
what have we done?
So the sooner you can get
over with the faster--
And this is achieved
through all the things
that we talked about.
It's just a data point
here of a customer for us
and move 700 VMs,
again, in six month.
And we'll hear more about from
Louis about how they did it.
So I think just
to wrap up, we've
developed those best practices,
determining the workloads
for migration.
Using discovery assessment
is really important.
I think Louis will
reiterate it over that.
Building that pipeline, automate
it, and really get going.
So with that, I want
to invite Louis,
and he'll tell you actually they
tools to do it in large scale.
Come on, Louis.
LOUIS VERZI: Thank you, Issy.
So I want to start
off by telling you
a little bit about
who is Cardinal
Health, because a lot of you may
not recognize our company name.
We're not out there.
We don't do a lot
of marketing, but we
have over 50,000 employees
throughout the world.
We're a health care
supplier, for the most part.
Supply chain is the big
part of our industry,
but we're moving a lot
into data analytics
and providing other solutions
to the health care market.
But we're really about making
health care more efficient,
providers more effective
and, most important, patients
as healthy as possible.
We're number 14 on the
Fortune 500, 136 billion
in annual revenue.
Our two primary
business segments
are pharmaceutical and medical.
So what was our main goal
for going to the cloud?
And really, I'm sure
everyone in this room
can appreciate that health care
costs are a primary concern
in many people's minds.
so keeping health
care costs as low
as humanly possible for
the patients we support,
cost is a huge factor
in our line of business.
So in addition to cost,
the ability to move quickly
and to be agile and to be able
to respond to business needs.
We're huge drivers in our
decision to move to the cloud.
How can we accomplish that?
How can we accomplish
those cost savings?
We really were out to eliminate
the inefficiencies that
come with managing
on-prem infrastructure,
all the costs that
are both visible
and that aren't
quite so visible.
We looked at how
many hours we spent
not just from our
infrastructure teams,
but our application
teams on firmware
upgrades, patching, updating
hardware, doing tech refresh.
It was millions of
dollars that the company
was having to spend to keep all
this infrastructure up to date
and to keep it running.
Just some inefficiency
examples from an on-prem type
environment.
Hardware acquisition,
it could take--
I'm sure you all have
procurement processes
that you have a budget,
you have to apply
for funding six months in
advance to your budget year.
And you hope that the $20
million that is available.
And $80 million worth of
funding were requested.
Are you going to be able to get
any of that funding available?
Those kinds of things,
and months to get hardware
procured to get it deployed.
And everyone over purchased
because they didn't
know how much they needed.
They had to request that funding
months or a year in advance.
By the time they actually
delivered a solution,
there was no money left
available to build upon that.
So they'd just get as
much as they possibly
could to make sure that
they had plenty of room.
Application teams are
slowed down significantly
by unneeded
cross-functional needs.
We are a very
siloed organization.
If you needed a
system built, there
was seven different
teams you needed
to engage to get that virtual
machine up and running.
And there's a lot of time
that's lost in that too.
So it's not just getting
the amount of labor
that spent there but
the amount of churn time
that you get to actually
spend those systems up.
And tech sprawl, right?
All of the extra hardware
that people bought,
that was taking up space
in our data center.
It was taking up electricity
and cooling our data center.
People hoarded hardware.
When they stopped
using the system,
do you think they told
IT they're done using it?
No.
They kept it around.
They kept it running, because
I might need to run that.
I might need that
for something later.
We actually found that
throughout our cloud migration
process, we decommissioned
to 20% of what
was in our data center, because
it wasn't being used anymore.
So that was a huge cost.
We've been patching that.
We've been doing firmware
upgrades on those systems.
People wouldn't
share, because they'd
be hoarding that to themselves.
So some key objectives that we
found for our transformation.
We wanted to kickstart
agility and speed
we wanted to reduce our
hardware acquisition burdens.
We wanted to empower
our application teams.
A very quick example,
when we looked
at our caseload
for our server team
and the number of
cases that came in,
60% of the cases
that they got were
from a development team saying,
can you restart my server?
And do you think that got
done when they needed it done,
or do you think it waited three
to five days for that SLA?
Let IT drive business,
not infrastructure.
We want to be doing the right
thing for the right reasons.
Reducing unneeded
labor and cost,
and also deploy self-service.
This was key to us achieving
a lot of the efficiencies
that we were looking
for as we needed
to enable self-service
to our application teams.
So, about a year into
our cloud migration,
we decided to take another
look at what we're doing.
We had originally picked
another cloud provider.
At the time, it was the only
enterprise-grade cloud around.
Then that cloud entered
the health business.
Surprise.
So it obviously started
prompting some questions
in our business's mind and
in our customer's mind.
Are we on the right
cloud platform for us?
So we started an RFP.
We wanted to determine really
which cloud provider was
the best cloud provider,
not just because of business
drivers, but for
technological drivers, too.
If that cloud provider really
was the best solution, well,
we're going to
have to suck it up,
because we were going to
have to do business, right?
If you're going to
continue being competitive,
we needed to be
getting into the cloud,
but obviously, we wanted
to see for ourselves.
Ultimately, GCP was
the cloud for us.
The things that
drove this decision
was a centralized organization,
a top-level organization, where
you can federate your accounts.
Users have one
place to log into.
They don't have to switch roles.
They don't have
to switch regions.
to switch accounts
to try to access their
services or systems.
Individual projects
for application teams
really provide the autonomy.
We couldn't do
self-service before,
because you couldn't scale
to hundreds of accounts
in that other cloud provider.
But you couldn't have
300 application teams
each have their own account.
It was not scalable.
So projects really
gave that autonomy
to our application teams.
And then shared
VPC concept really
allowed us to give
that autonomy,
but still, put enterprise
guardrails in place so we
could protect the enterprise.
We needed to protect egress.
We needed to protect ingress.
Ease of granting access.
There were no difficult
roles to have to understand.
It was much, much
easier to deliver
self-service to our
application teams.
So we had a clear
winner in all the areas
that we were looking for.
In addition to the
future technology,
Google is a highly innovative.
And new things are coming
out very, very frequently
in the data analytics
space, everywhere,
in machine learning.
So in Kubernetes, these were
all also important to us,
not just for today's needs but
for tomorrow's needs as well.
So as you mentioned
building our agile migration
factor in how we
actually migrate stuff,
so we chose a two-week
sprint process, where,
within that first week, we would
invest heavily on discovery
work and really understanding
what that application did,
how it worked, what
it communicated with,
what load balancers were in
front of it, what DNS names,
where someone may
have had a static IP
address that they hid in
their configuration somewhere.
And then the second week, we'd
get into migration preparation.
We'd be building those
automated runbooks.
We'd be preparing scripts
for updating DNS and doing
our updating single
sign-on, preparing
firewall rules, et cetera, with
the end of that cycle being
the actual migration, and then
application smoke testing.
So this was very
successful for us.
Since we were going
in to experience,
it also gave us the opportunity
to really iterate and improve
upon our processes.
So keys to migration
success, start small.
We didn't start with our most
complex production applications
to migrate into the cloud.
We started with the dev
systems, the test systems.
The very early dev
test systems as we
did with friendly application
teams that we knew.
You all know the
difference between
the friendly application
teams and the non-friendly
application teams.
Declare small early victories,
get comfortable with the cloud.
It's new.
It's a big change for everyone.
Starting small really lets
you have that opportunity
to understand what you're doing,
discover the road bumps you're
going to run into and
then iterate and improve
on those processes.
Building a cloud
culture is important.
The most difficult thing
about cloud migration
isn't migrating systems.
The most difficult thing
about cloud migration
is changing the people,
changing the processes.
So we put a lot of focus
on that organizationally
to be able to improve upon that.
What ways we kept
off the momentum?
We use this as an opportunity
to train people on new skills?
We gamified migrations.
We had prizes.
Which application team could
migrate the most systems
within a month?
Which teams would be
first into production?
Those kind of things.
We gave individual
projects a code name.
We had a lot of fun.
We had posters.
In the first phase
of our project,
every sprint had a movie
poster theme to it.
So we did a lot of
stuff to have fun.
We brought lots of food in,
because everyone loves food.
Back to cost savings.
I mentioned that is one
of our primary drivers.
How did we obtain cost savings?
Now, when you talk to
people about the cloud,
the first impression is,
oh, that's expensive.
Our migration to the cloud,
we had lean migration teams
that were highly focused
on what they were doing.
We upload our existing IT staff.
It wasn't a cleanse out
the whole IT department
and bring in new people.
It was bringing in people from
areas that would otherwise
be impacted.
When you're going to cloud,
your storage team goes away,
your networking
team reduces a lot,
your OS teams reduce,
your VMware team.
We brought a lot of those
infrastructure teams
into our migration program,
got them trained up.
And they were some
of the people that
were leading our actual
migration activities.
We right-sized VMs.
We found a lot of stuff
in our data center,
where this database server, it
was a physical database server.
It had 128 cores
and 512 giga memory.
And guess what?
It was running at 1% or 2%
CPU, and the database only
had 8 gig of memory
that it was running.
So there's a lot
of stuff oversized,
because they never knew what
they might need in the future.
Again, I mentioned that we
decommissioned about 20%
of systems.
We never had to
migrate THEM because
in talking to the
application teams,
they weren't really using them.
And when they found out, we
were covering cloud costs year
one, but year two,
they'd have those costs.
It made them think twice about
whether they really needed
that system that they
were hoarding anymore,
especially when
we're giving them
the keys to be able to build
new systems as they needed them.
So 20% reduction
in our VM footprint
that we never had to migrate.
Something else, though, is
critical to our savings, that
was really a culture change
for application teams,
is only power on
your systems when
you need them most
application teams,
especially a lot of our
legacy applications,
they don't do frequent releases.
They're not hammering away
at their lower environments
frequently.
So our lower environments
are powered off 70%-80%
of the time; nights, weekends
business days when they're not
using them.
We put automated
processes in place
to be able to let application
teams tag their instance.
So at the time they
choose, every day
that system powers
off and give them
the choice of whether it
power on automatically
the next day or not.
So definitely powering
off your instances
when you don't need them as key
to saving money in the cloud.
I give the analogy
of always telling
my kids to turn off the lights
when they leave the room.
Do the same thing
with your servers.
When you leave for the day and
you're not using it, power it
off.
If you're going to be
in meetings all day,
don't power that server on.
Agility was also a driver.
Our time to cloud
dramatically decreased.
We moved thousands of
systems into the cloud
within a couple of years.
And that included taking about
three to four-month hiatus
to change our cloud provider.
A lot of work went into that.
Just in time infrastructure.
Application teams have the
ability to spin up instances
when they need them, spin
them down, delete them
if they don't need them.
Again, they have self-service,
no more cumbersome procurement
process.
Application teams
have a cloud budget,
and they choose how to
spend that cloud budget
if they are going to
exceed that budget
and it just happens to be in
the same bucket as their labor
bucket.
So they really have
the ability to switch
a lot of levers for
departments to be
able to make their budgets.
And the application
teams feel empowered.
empowered.
So really feel empowered to be
in control of their destiny.
They can do what they need done.
They can achieve
their business goals
without relying on
infrastructure teams.
And people were convinced.
People who were worried
about their role
are excited about
the new technology
and learning new skills while
still at Cardinal Health.
App teams who are
worried about the cloud
love their newfound
empowerment and agility.
And compliance teams
worried about regulations
now realize that
HIPAA, FDA, GDPR; these
are all easier to achieve in
the cloud, not more difficult.
There's so much more technology
available to you in the cloud
than you could ever build
in your own data center.
And you will hit speed bumps.
Don't expect this to be all
roses and cherry on top.
Everything's not easy.
People are going to have
fear, uncertainty, and doubt.
You need to remove that
fear, uncertainty, and doubt
by sharing information,
being open and honest
with your people.
We establish a Cloud
Center of Expertise
to really uplift the
entire organization.
We held training events
we partnered with Google
to bring in experts from across
the field, whether it was
Kubernetes, or infrastructure,
or machine learning,
or data and analytics.
We really brought our teams up
to speed on current technology.
And really you need to energize
the base of your teams.
From a process perspective,
industry validation,
compliance updating SOPs.
There is a lot of process
things that come up
that you need to adapt to.
And being flexible and
adaptive are important aspects
of moving to the cloud.
It's not going to be--
We joke that-- when
we find something
that works and find a
standard-- that, hey,
that's our standard this month.
But we don't know what's going
to come next month, because we
don't know what challenges
are going to be facing us.
From a technology perspective,
shared platforms are difficult.
Shared databases, and I know
you shouldn't share databases,
but our application
teams did it.
Web servers that you may have
15 different applications on.
Those are a little
bit difficult to move.
They take a little
bit more time.
Firewall rules.
For north-south
communication, you
need to understand
your firewall rules.
Ingress and egress proxies, for
us, it was legacy SiteMinder.
And a lot of that
configuration wasn't
at the top of everyone's mind,
because that's been there
and sitting for a while.
Load balancers can be difficult.
And network-attached storage,
don't forget about that.
You move your
machines, guess what?
You need to move their network
attached storage with it.
So as an SMB, don't forget
about those, because we
had some surprises there.
Lessons learned, we iterated.
We were continually improving
our process after every sprint,
making sure that the roadblocks
that we ran into that we
don't run into them again.
In parallel discovery.
Don't just try to do all
your discovery upfront
and then move to migration.
You won't gain the momentum.
You also want to make
sure that you're not
overanalyzing things
and not progressing,
because you're trying to
do too much discovery.
Although I will say
too much discovery
is a hard thing to achieve,
but don't spend too much time
overanalyzing things.
Automate everything as
he talked about runbooks.
We've gotten to the
point towards the end
of our migration here that when
it comes to migration time,
it's literally someone
pushes a button,
and the migrations
occur, DNS is updated,
the DNS configuration on
the boxes are updated,
software is installed,
software is uninstalled.
And there's very little
human interaction needed
with migrations, because
as we ran into things,
no one likes to do the same
thing more than once or twice.
And if you're migrating
thousands of systems,
you don't want to do the same
thing thousands of times.
ISSY BEN-SHAUL: For sure.
LOUIS VERZI: Make a
migration checklist,
so you don't forget things and
batch your migration waves.
As he talked about 50
to 100, that number
really worked well for us.
Most of our migration waves
were between 50 and 100 systems.
And that was very
manageable for us.
It allowed us to get
our scale and our speed,
but without having too much
that we were overwhelmed.
A final note, keep it
fun and have pizza.
Everyone loves pizza.
Amazon coined the phrase
about the two pizza team.
That didn't work for us.
I like two pizzas myself,
so I wouldn't get very far
by myself.
But we really had a lot of fun.
We really worked hard, and
we ate a lot of food too.
So, with that, I will
hand it over to Issy
to share some roadmap items.
ISSY BEN-SHAUL: Thanks, mate.
Good job.
[APPLAUSE]
I thank Louis and his team for
being a great product for us.
When they moved to the first
cloud, we were still a startup.
And we help them move
to the first cloud,
and then we did the
second move with them too.
The good thing is
that the service
is free for people who want
to move to GCP, the migration
service.
Everything is free, as long as
you move to the right cloud.
I would have said just
one minute about what
was announced today.
And again, by the way, Cardinal
is one of our good design
partners on the next step.
So while you've seen now
the lift and shift is
a very viable possibility
for large scale migrations,
we also see more and more
customers asking us, hey,
but once we move to
the cloud, can we
can get some help in
modernizing workloads,
making them more containerized?
Can we get some
operational efficiencies
of the cloud, developer
productivity, et cetera?
And many of them
have tried or two--
And again, we're not
talking cloud-native
but rather about existing
legacy applications.
What can be done there?
The commercial of the shelf
tools, et cetera, software.
And when they start to get
through this process manually,
they find out that this is very
hard and challenging process.
And that let us think
about what can we
do to help those customers
not only migrate to the Cloud
but also modernize.
And I don't have time
to elaborate that.
There are actually multiple
sessions on that are given,
but just give you a glimpse
of what we've basically done.
And that was the essence of
the announcement that was made
in the keynote about
Anthos-Migrate, which is--
We came up with
this solution that
allows you essentially rely
on the infrastructure layer
that we talk today for
transport and streaming.
But, in addition to that, we're
able to take essentially VMs,
and essentially strip all the
system elements that we take,
just the user mode
applications workload,
and essentially convert
them into Kubernetes,
detach the network and storage
that they've been working with
and the operating system
kernel, et cetera,
and reconnect them into
Kubernetes, or particularly,
in GKE networking,
storage, et cetera.
And what happens is that,
out of this process,
using streaming but
also the transformation,
we're now getting really
in a zero-touch matter--
VMs that we're running
previously on-prem
running as actual Kubernetes
or actually GKE containers
and getting some of that
benefits out of the door
right away.
For instance, you don't have
to deal with operating system
patches or security.
You don't have to deal
with all the things
that come with a VM-based.
Like for instance, you
can get the benefits
of networking security.
You can gather all the benefits
of visibility, monitoring,
logging.
All this comes out of
the box without having
to deal with anything.
And that has been really a jump.
Now, once we do that, we
can also add what's called
[INAUDIBLE] and extend the
capability or augment it
by virtual--
For instance, putting
these two sidecar,
which gives you a service
mesh capability, visibility,
network security, all this.
And all this is done without
making any single line
of change in the code.
Now, this is our first only--
we'll call phase
one, and it gives you
the operational benefits of GKE.
And what we are working on
and will release soon after
is the ability also to
leverage the productivity
through CI/CD pipelines.
And that will be done by
actually not only migrating
the VMs but also
breaking them down,
taking the docker images,
containers, elements out.
They're artifacts and
being able for you
to use image-based
management in the right way.
So this is coming later
and leveraging the tools
that we have today to
introspect in Kubernetes.
The dependencies and
use that in order
to actually further
break down the monolith.
This is something that
will come down the road,
but we don't have
much time for that.
I just wanted to give
you a glimpse of that.
We actually are working with
a number of design partners
to further elaborate and
develop the solution.
One of them is Cardinal.
And the interesting
thing to keep in mind
is that our approach
to Anthos-Migrate
is such that we want to meet
the customer where they are.
What I mean by that is that
you can actually transform VMs
to containers, whether
you're on-premises,
whether you're in another
cloud, or whether you're
already in GCP but have
not migrate yet to GKE.
So you can migrate first
and modernize later.
For instance, Cardinal Health
has done thousands of VMs,
but they are looking now
and further modernizing.
And they can do that
with Anthos-Migrate
from GCP into GKE.
We also will support the
ability to move to GKE On-Prem,
and then you can, from there on,
move from GKE On-Prem to GKE.
And, finally, we also
support workloads
that are running in
any other clouds--
I mean AWS-- and they
can move either to GCP
or directly into GKE.
So all options are
ordered to give you
the flexibility
you need to decide
whether you want
to modernize first,
migrate later, or vice versa.
Are we getting
really out of time?
We have one minute
for questions.
So thank you very much
for listening to us.
OK.
We're going to be here
a few minutes if someone
wants to come and have
some questions offline.
But thank you very much
for attending today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]